Olá pessoal aqui Dr al Machado Dutra
médico há mais de 25 anos e hoje eu
trago um tema bem sério porém é curioso
e um pouco inusitado que é a relação
entre cutucar o nariz e a doença de
alzheimer é pessoal aquele hábito de
limpar o nariz que muitas pessoas têm
mas que poucos admitem recentes estudos
têm sugerido uma possível ligação entre
cutucar o nariz e um aumento no risco de
desenvolver a doença de alzheimer isso
mesmo a A ideia é que esse hábito pode
aumentar a inflamação no cérebro o que
por sua vez poderia contribuir para o
desenvolvimento dessa forma de demência
que tanto nos preocupa a demência de
Alzheimer não é só sobre esquecer as
coisas essa doença infeliz interfere na
nossa clareza mental atrapalha as
atividades diárias e o que é realmente
triste pode apagar nossas memórias Então
vamos lá primeiro você sabia que um
estudo de 1995 revelou que 91% dos
entrevistados admitiram que cou com o
nariz Parece que é algo quase Universal
não é mesmo os motivos vão desde tirar
aquela meleca incômoda até hábitos
nervosos que podem virar uma compulsão
Então pessoal para entender como cutucar
o nariz pode estar associado ao
Alzheimer Precisamos falar sobre
inflamação crônica sabiam que a
inflamação crônica está no centro de
muitas doenças modernas estamos falando
de problemas como doenças cardíacas
câncer demência doença autoimune e até
hepatite crônica uma revisão feita pela
Western Sydney University sugere que a
neuroinflamação crônica que para os
autores do estudo pode ser desencadeada
por cutucar o nariz poderia contribuir
pro desenvolvimento da doença de
alzheimer parece algo simples mas
cutucar o nariz com muita frequência
pode ter consequências eu vou deixar o
link desse estudo e dos outros estudos
na descrição para vocês darem uma olhada
depois agora vamos ent Ender um pouco
sobre o microbioma o conjunto de
bactérias que vive o nosso intestino
assim como o intestino Nossa cavidade
nasal também tem o seu próprio conjunto
de microrganismos que nos protegem de
várias maneiras pesquisadores sugerem
que alterar esse microbioma nasal por
meio de hábitos como cutucar o nariz
pode sim mudar a maneira como esses
patógenos essas bactérias ruins as
bactérias do Mal podem se espalhar e até
atingir o cérebro contribuindo para tal
neuroinflamação crônica em estudos com
animais realizados em 2022 descobriu-se
que bactérias como a Clamídia pneumoni
pode infectar o sistema nervoso central
através do nariz viajando pelos nervos
olfativos ou seja o nervo responsável
por captar o cheiro e também o nervo
trigêmeo que é um dos principais nervos
na nossa Face e com isso pode atingir o
cérebro e aumentar o risco de Alzheimer
e tem mais um artigo na revista biomol
queos analisou e mostrou como vírus
bactérias e fungos Associados à doença
de alzheimer podem iniciar essa
inflamação no cérebro através do sistema
olfativo através do nariz então estudos
também mostraram que infecções
periodontais que bagunçam o microbioma
da boca estão cada vez mais ligadas ao
aumento do risco de Alzheimer
pesquisadores encontraram uma composição
alterada na microbioma oral ou seja na
boca de pessoas com Alzheimer incluindo
bactérias que estão diret ligadas à
formação das placas amiloides que são um
dos principais achados patológicos da
doença um dos principais indicadores
outra coisa importante a ser considerada
é que com o passar dos anos a composição
do microbioma nasal muda e começa a se
assemelhar mais àquela encontrada na
área orofaringe ou seja na garganta e
essa mudança influencia diretamente a
microflora nasal e pode ter um papel no
desenvolvimento de doenças
neurodegenerativas existe uma conexão
bidirecional nas duas direções entre a
microbiota nasal e doenças como
Alzheimer Isso significa que alterações
no nosso nariz podem afetar o cérebro e
vice-versa na realidade os pesquisadores
apontam que os patógenos podem invadir o
cérebro através do sistema olfativo
contribuindo paraa neuroinflamação
típica encontrar na doença de alzheimer
mas aqui surge uma questão intrigante
que que vem primeiro ovo à Galinha né
Será que foi um sistema imunológico já
comprometido que levou a neuroinflamação
e por sua vez o Alzheimer ou foi ao
contrário será que a inflamação
relacionada à idade e ao início do
Alzheimer é que desencadeou falha no
sistema imune permitindo que esses
patógenos entrassem e causassem a
neuroinflamação então não sabemos ainda
e ficamos no aguardo de mais estudos
pessoal entre os patógenos os bichos
encontrados no cérebro de pessoas com
alheim tá o parasita Toxoplasma onde
também o vírus do herpis e as bactérias
que causam pneumonia e não podemos
esquecer do Papel super importante da
nossa microbiota intestinal alterações
nela também podem afetar a nossa saúde
oral e consequentemente o cérebro isso
destaca a importância de cuidar da saúde
intestinal como uma prioridade pois ela
pode estar diretamente ligada ao risco
de desenvolver
Alzheimer essa informação nos mostra
como o corpo humano é interconectado
alterações em uma parte pode e afetar
outras áreas de maneira que estamos
apenas começando a entender tudo isso os
autores desse estudo recente também
alertam que algo tão simples quanto
melhorar a higiene das mãos pode ser um
passo preventivo crucial especialmente
pros nossos idosos agora por que que
você deveria pensar duas vezes antes de
levar as mãos ao nariz de maneira
repetida bom você deve evitar esse
hábito especialmente se você estiver
doente ou com sistema de defesa
enfraquecido a cavidade nasal é um
verdadeiro reservatório de patógenos que
podem se espalhar facilmente Vejam Só
estudos mostram que o microbioma nasal
muda com a idade e após a exposição há
várias infecções e condições
imunológicas Isso significa que o perfil
do seu microbioma nasal pode influenciar
diretamente a sua resposta de defesa
imune por exemplo dados de 2018
revelaram que até 30% das pessoas são
colonizadas permanentemente pelo
estafilococos áureos na cavidade nasal
mesmo sem apresentar sintomas e aqueles
que têm o hábito de cutucar o nariz
estão muito mais expostos a uma maior
colonização o que pode levar a infecções
oportunistas inclusive em locais
cirúrgicos Além disso pode desenvolver
infecções graves especialmente se as
unhas deixarem pequenos cortes no tecido
nasal então esses cortes podem ser
portas de entrada para bactérias na
corrente sanguínea um estudo de 2023
mostrou que os profissionais saúde que
cutuca o nariz tinha um risco aumentado
de contrair viroses outras infecções
oportunistas podem se espalhar e causar
pneumonia otite média asma e
rinosinusite crônica Então vamos prestar
atenção a mensagem aqui é Clara pessoal
manter uma boa higiene das mãos evitar
de cutucar o nariz são práticas simples
que podem ajudar a proteger nossa saúde
de várias maneiras e claro se você é uma
pessoa com esse hábito não fica
assustado ou assustada achando que vai
ficar com alheimer existem vários outros
gatilhos PR doença e mais pesquisas
precisam ser feit Para comprovar essa
teoria
[Música]
OK não esqueça de curtir esse vídeo
compartilhar com quem precisa dessa
informação sua participa
para continuarmos abordamos temas tão
importantes para nossa saúde muito
obrigado pela sua atenção um grande
abraço beijo no coração você é fera